wir schalten wir live an die frankfurter
börse zu albrecht humboldt albrecht wie
ist die stimmung
[Musik]
oliver werde ich das angebot gehen doch
mal in hünhan gab wirklich mit reis soja
dem man feiern die rheinmetall aktionäre
ja da kommt die wodka pistole
kinder ich komme ich mache eine schalte
klar sind die happy jetzt wo die gruppe
weiter geht ja aber es heißt doch immer
lieferungen in drittstaaten also weder
eu noch nato werden die ausnahme jetzt
höre ich 60 prozent unserer exporte sind
in den letzten jahren genau dahin
gegangen
unter unseren zehn größten waffen kunden
sind alleine drei länder die aktiv am
krieg im jemen beteiligt sind ja da
möchte ich einfach mal den großen franz
josef strauß zitieren was haben denn
waffen bitte außerhalb von
krisengebieten zu suchen
ja also hier dieser cdu-abgeordnete fast
ist sehr schön zusammen
wir arbeiten zwar nicht immer draht mit
den leuchttürmen der menschlichkeit und
demokratie zusammen mit luft das würde
auch jeder im zweifel zustimmen aber man
muss auch manchmal nehmen was da ist ja
nehmen was da ist das kennen sie aus der
disco nacht zum 2 nein weit vor allem
die von rheinmetall machen das schon
super
die verkaufen zum beispiel komplette
munitionsfabrik in krisenregionen
schlüsselfertig wie bei ikea hier das
modell kann der araber dann selbst
zusammenbauen der in jemen werden ja
immer wieder rheinmetall bomben entdeckt
aber eben nicht in deutschland gebaut
sondern von einer tochterfirma auf
sardinien
die deutschen behörden können einfach
sagen dass diese speziellen munition und
ausrüstungen in italien produziert
worden
die italiener wiederum betrachten sie
als deutsche produkte so wird der handel
mit waffen viel weniger streng
kontrolliert als der weltweite handel
mit bananen zurecht bananen
brandgefährlich wenn die nicht richtig
reif sind da kommen sie vom pott kann
nicht mehr runter
aber verstehen sie wie clever
rheinmetall das macht diese waffen
tauchen in der deutschen rüstungsgüter
nicht mehr
ich verstehe das heißt das funktioniert
im grunde wie so ein franchise ganz
genau hier
rheinmetall hat in riad gerade das erste
waffen drive-in eröffnet das ist eine
super idee eine panzerfaust und eine
kleine
allah akhbar ja aber wie gesagt
offiziell sind deutsche
waffenlieferungen in drittstaaten
verboten
[Applaus]